joining us now more reaction from the
White House plus an update on reopening
the country press secretary Kelly
mcenany this goes far deep and wide
Kaylee by the way congratulations on you
knew well I should actually say
condolences because how I would never
want my and anybody that I like in the
world to deal with these jackasses in
the media like you do every day why you
took that job I have no idea but you're
doing great congratulations the
seriousness of what's at stake here is
real yeah it is very real Sean you know
the fact that on January 4th they're
about to close the case into Michael
Flynn a case that should have never
existed because there was no collusion
we now have several Obama administration
officials on record saying that they're
about to close it and in this Oval
Office discussion takes place with
President Obama who the DOJ Sally Yates
learns from the President of the United
States about this conversation and runs
back to the Department of Justice in a
panic not knowing how the President of
the United States even knows about this
conversation and then to find out all of
the unmasking there are very real very
serious questions here this was a huge
injustice not just to President Trump in
his administration but to the American
people by the way the next time somebody
in the mob and the media asks you if
you're going to lie to them say I can
guarantee you I will lie a lot less than
all of you in this room combined how's
that fair answer okay that's why I'll
never I'll never be able to do your job
all right Kate very fair answer Sean